الرائحة الأولى لمنزل جديد ومن أجل
هذه النمور والأسود التي تم إنقاذها من السيرك ،
كانت لحظاتهم الأخيرة محصورة مثل
هذه النمور عالقة في هذا القفص
لأكثر من 36 ساعة لكنها عاشت في
أقفاص كهذه طوال حياتها
لتتعامل بوحشية من أجل الترفيه عن البشر من
أجل  Animal Defenders international
كانت واحدة من أعقد
عمليات إنقاذ 12 نمورًا وخمسة خطوط في إجمالي 18
شهرًا من النضال في غواتيمالا في
معركة استمرت 30 عامًا لحظر السيرك للحيوانات على
مستوى العالم حتى الآن 45 دولة بما في ذلك
غواتيمالا هل تتخيلها
بسبب الأداء الذي قدمه الحيوان
يستمتعون بأنفسهم وخلف
الستار تمكنا من إظهار أنه
لا يمكن أن يكون أكثر من غير صحيح ما هو
وراء الستار الوحشي الحرمان من إساءة المعاملة القاسية
ولكن القطط التي يتم إنقاذها
مكلفة ويأمل آدي أن يكون هذا المرفق الجديد المخصص
في جنوب إفريقيا
حافزًا لـ  المزيد من الحكومات التي تحذو
حذوها ، حيث يقوم المتعاملون بتفريغ حمولة
الأسرة الأولى من النمور ،
حيث تم اقتلاع مخالبهم كأشبال.
البعض كان لديه سيف أنياب من قبل
مدربي السيرك لكنهم ما زالوا نمورًا
بالضبط لماذا يقولون إنه
لم يكن ينبغي أبدًا حبسهم في أقفاص لتبدأ الآن
بخطواتها المبدئية الأولى نحو
حياة جديدة David McKenzie CNN Free State
South Africa